jam-packed highways are a familiar sight
in Germany artists Amata's curette knows
when we see a traffic jam coming up most
of us think damn now it's going to take
longer I just want to go home
I really can't use a traffic jam now but
this driver has actually sought this one
out Montes is the passenger for once the
drivers pay to bag Miller head of Audis
pilot and driving project Montes notice
that Peter actually seemed to be looking
forward to the traffic jam Peter points
out a great function this a 8 has that
helps take some of the stress out of
traffic jams Peter explains that the
traffic jam assists the driver leave the
driving to the car so the car not the
driver takes over the driving thinks
that sounds practical and wonders how it
works
Peter explains the car recognizes that
it can handle the driving conditions he
presses this button on the center
console to switch the system on Malthus
observes that now both passenger and
driver can concentrate on other matters
Peter confirms this for example they
could watch TV here in the center
console at present these systems are not
street-legal in any country but the
developers are hoping that will change
much as with an airplanes autopilot
they're piloted systems come with double
and triple safety systems
Peter explains that Audi developed
sensors for the a8 based on three
principles one is a laser scanner that
reveals what's happening all around as
well as the detailed contours of the
cars nearby another is radar sensors
that look ahead and to the sides and
there's a camera that also keeps watch
on the area head the traffic jam
assistant functions through the
interaction of all these sensors not
just wonders what happens if one of the
sensors fails Pater says if that happens
the system requests that the driver take
over of great importance is that no
matter what the failure the system
ensures that the car proceeds safely in
its own lane until the driver takes over
in the worst case it stops without
causing a collision apparently the worst
that can happen is that the car itself
might cause a traffic jam but in heavy
traffic more is involved in driving than
just accelerating and braking Montes
points out that now they're stuck in
slow-moving traffic an accident may have
occurred somewhere ahead so you'll have
to make sure the ambulances have room to
get through between the cars well the
system do that too Peter confirms it
will the car recognizes its lane and
automatically moves out of the emergency
corridor for example their car is in the
left lane so it pulls to the left edge
in case the emergency vehicles need to
pass on the right Montez describes
Audi's traffic jam a system is very
convenient and easy to operate just as
he did imagined using an autopilot ought
to be but he still hopes the traffic jam
will break up soon he has to get to the
airship hangar and moon I'm good Peter
take him there Peter obliges no problem
once inside a car people generally see
only what's happening close by to get
the bigger picture regarding a traffic
jam you have to take to the air here the
advantage of an airship is that it
doesn't fly very fast
mid-meal in the airship with montez's
professor misha else Reichenberg a
physicist who researches traffic jams
he's at a university in one of the most
congested regions of Germany the s in
Duisburg area the Ruhr Valley has lots
of traffic anyway he asked professor
striking back how a traffic jam like the
one below comes about he doesn't see any
accidents
professor striking Berg explains a 60 to
70 percent of all traffic jams are
caused purely by congestion which means
too many vehicles using the same road in
the same direction at the same time
roads have a limited capacity this Asif
a traffic jam assisted Audi's developed
for the new a8 will prevent traffic jams
or will it simply help the driver who's
already stuck in one professor strikin
Berg thinks the traffic jam assistant
will help to harmonize traffic
he believes technology is better able
than people to adapt to conditions in
heavy traffic so it will hit the brakes
and hit the gas as little as possible it
goes with a flow and it has far better
reaction times that makes the ride more
relaxing for the driver and it's better
for the other cars the more vehicles are
equipped like that the less often these
waves of traffic jams will occur
[Music]
back down to earth and the present if
worse comes to worst
can we really entrust our lives to
control systems and sensors let's put it
to the test
Montes is in the driver's seat another
car is straight ahead what should he do
Pater suggests that he turned on the
adaptive cruise control they'll start
off behind another car then he could
switch on the traffic jam assist at
around 55 km/h the system messages the
driver to take control Peter tells
Montes to do nothing and see what
happens mata starts off switches on the
traffic jam assistant and does nothing
more peter confirms that the system is
asking the driver to take control now
Montes wonders if he shouldn't do
something he doesn't want to rear-end
the car ahead but then it's not slowing
down he can feel the breaking in his
seatbelt and now they've come safely to
a stop
Martis is impressed that the technology
is so advanced all we need now is for
the authorities to legalize it for use
on public roads it's been ready for some
time now